bonjour monsieur fillon marie laure
phinéra horth
sénatrice de la guyane alors je vous
poserai trois questions comment
articuler la politique maritime
nationale avec les politiques maritimes
locales défini dans leur champ de
compétence par les collectivités
territoriales
comment mieux adapter les moyens
d'action de l'état en mer à l'ampleur
des phénomènes de narcotrafic et de
pêche illégale dans la z de guyane aise
et au niveau de violence des
contrevenants et enfin compte tenu de
l'éloignement et de l'absence
d'infrastructures
comment envisager le développement de
campagnes d'exploitation des ressources
maritimes dans les es2 française
l'ampleur des narco trafics maritimes et
la pêche illégale dans la z guyanais et
le niveau de violence des contrevenants
j'ai pas de réponse les questions que
pose et je crois qu'il faudrait la poser
aux autorités maritimes locales
je crois qu'elles ne sont pas
entièrement défaillante
l'action des marinas saisissant les
narcotrafics repose en bonne partie sur
la coopération internationale avec la
garde côtes américaine avec un marine
américaine avec avec les pays bas il ya
un gros travail des changes de
renseignement qui se fait avec le look
trice est très impliquée dans ces
affaires-là
les opérations ne impliquant la marine
et les autres avec l'aide des autres
armées le commandant la zone maritime
sous l'autorité du délégué du gouverneur
noir de martinique fonctionne et est le
couvre tout l'arc tout l'arc antillais
jusqu'à la guyenne bon voilà il ya un
suivi qui est fait il est insuffisant de
l'explosion des des prises
montrent à quel point ce trafic est
encore en voie d'expansion
et on a peut-être impression de vide et
la mère la petite cuillère bon voila il
faudra mettre des moyens cela aussi
c'est une question de je pense que c'est
une question de moyens les procédures de
coopération internationale comme les
procédures juridiques fonctionne
maintenant c'est une question de moyens
qu'il faut y mettre
s'agissant des pêcheurs
du niveau de paix des pêcheurs bien je
rappelle que nous sommes dans une eau
plus ce sont des opérations de police et
que dans les opérations de police
l'emploi de la force est contraint par
le code pénal et que
nous ne peut les forces de police ne
peuvent agir que dans le cas de la
légitime défense et même s'il est
le mode d'action si les règles
d'engagement sont de plus en plus
affinée et ajustés nous ne sommes pas
dans le cadre d'une opération de guerre
et donc tout emploi de la force qui
serait par trop préventif serait
condamnée par le juge et que donc il y à
une contrainte juridique et je dirais
même plus aux jeunes est une contrainte
de civilisation qui fait qu'on ne fait
pas la guerre à des contrevenants ont
fait une répression
dans le cadre de la loi ce sont les à la
fois les contraintes et le est ce qui
fait la grandeur de l'état de droit et
que nous devons appliquer dans cette
matière comme dans l'autre